foreign
[Music]
my name is Thomas and thanks for tuning
in today so today we are talking about
um a client portal that we've built for
a customer of ours in the Netherlands uh
where we used our shiny with embedded
power bi reports
and I practice my presentation
beforehand for some friends in Belgium
would not work in I.T sector and I
didn't understand a little thing so
hopefully you will understand something
both working for the I.T company axi and
we traveled all the way from Belgium
especially uh for you today
um yeah axi is a full certified partner
from our studio uh since 2020 and has a
sector-specific approach if there are
any questions during the presentation
you can always ask through slido or you
can find us at a stand next door and
have a little chat and coffee with us
so what can you expect during your talk
some insights why it's not always power
bi or air shiny but sometimes power bi
and are shiny we are going to present
some examples of the use of our shiny in
production and we have also some code
symbols for you and of course some
references to a famous man in uh bowtie
so why are we speaking here today uh six
months ago Rachel Dempsey from rstudio
had an online session with Paul Chang
from Microsoft about capacity planning
for Microsoft Azure data centers and my
colleague Thomas comment on the session
if Paul had ever considered about
embedding power bi dashboards which are
shiny in combination with Azure
functions that we have used for blimmer
apis and Paul had never seen this before
so we shall replied on that like I think
that's a great presentation too and
that's why we are here today
so the customer with what we realized
this project is a Dutch mortgage
portfolio Management Group or the npm
and the npm is part of the blur twist
group that is a group of company that
provide mortgage lending service
Services together with the entire
mortgage value chain and as an in
as an organization they can offer
institutional investors to to invest in
Dutch Residential Mortgages the npm
offers a portfolio management services
including providing access to an online
interactive dashboard call it the
mortgage management tool and on the
slide you can see some references yeah
some customers served by dmpm that are
famous banks in Europe
so as promised I was going to tell you
more about how the portal was before we
started so with the npm customers could
consult
um their insights of their portfolio
through the classical bi approach
I'm using click they could login and
they can save their their bookmarks and
filter with custom filters but however
these reports were separate from the
dmvm website and were not customized so
the npm has not full ownership of the
portal
so the npm wants to evolve their portal
um to a serious data science portal and
they want to provide their customers
with richer data and insights so this
this new portal had some requirements
like rendering Taylor documents
including forecast on time series I'm
still providing classical dashboards but
leveraging a new Azure data platform
with power bi they want because they
like to work in a customer oriented way
they want full control of the look and
feel and the user experience
and they also want to keep ownership of
the portal and of course the portal
needs to be future-proofed
so where shiny is often toughed as a
dashboarding tool and it plays like the
categories like power bi or Tableau but
are shiny is more than that
um a shiny can be used for data science
applications including dashboards full
stack web development and real-time
prediction applications
as you can see here from the graph a
shiny has a very strong business
capability rating a better learning
curve is a bit more difficult than a
power bi or a tableau
since error is a an open source
languages there are several packages
available and together with the npm we
have chosen for a markdown a shiny and
plumber this allowed us to create
interactive web applications and by
using our markdown we were able to
generate our tailored documents like PDF
we use plumber to separate the logic in
different functions
in every project you encounter different
challenges so we had some challenges on
bi and data science level but also on
Azure level
can you combine bi tools with data
science Solutions should we combined
power bi or shiny or redevelop in pure
Arc and how we can embed a power bi
dashboard
did we manage it yes we did but my
colleague yorandi will tell uh more in
detail how we did it
thank you Thomas
um so when looking at the already
existing Integrations between the the
more common bi tools and our we see that
our R actually a lot of options uh first
of all it's easy to use in our python
script in your data preparation use
custom visuals within your bi tools that
originate from r or python or even use a
polymer API to for instance embed a
forecast of your data
so integrating R in your bi tools isn't
that difficult the other way around
however can pose some challenges
typically the only way to integrate a bi
tool into your our data product is by by
embedding it
when looking at the integration
capabilities of wnr for instance we see
two major packages shiny Tableau and
Plymouth Tableau shiny Tableau being
used for using shiny in your Tableau
dashboards and plumber Tableau you can
use to use an API written in r in your
tableau's calculated fields
power bi also offers quite some some R
Integrations for instance it's very easy
to get your data using an R script or to
use our powered visuals in your power bi
dashboards
so with these two examples I think it's
quite clear that using R in your more
common bi tools is quite straightforward
the other way around however that's
another question
for instance how would you and this is
also the topic of the stock embed a
power bi dashboard in your our shiny
application
if you want to use a dashboard that was
written in power bi in our shiny
application the first question that
arised for us was whether or not we
should we could also just migrate the
existing visuals to our shiny
application this way power bi serves
more as a design tool where we kind of
see what works somewhat doesn't and the
final visuals are recreated in our shiny
application
this is an interesting approach if you
have dashboards that don't evolve a lot
that don't change a lot and you have
people who feel comfortable working in R
and shiny
the option of embedding is more
interesting if you have dashboards that
do change and evolve a lot this way you
can
update your dashboards without having to
re-publish your app every time
furthermore you can have a team that's
really dedicated on maintaining the
power bi dashboards who don't need to
have any shiny knowledge for our case we
were definitely in the second category
where we had a team of people who didn't
necessarily possess the correct amount
of shiny knowledge and we had dashboards
that changed and evolved a lot
but how does embedding a power bi
dashboard work exactly well the first
thing we do is write the application and
the general structure of the application
itself in R and shiny
next we use our power bi and its drag
and drop features to create a nice
looking dashboard and thereafter we
simply embed the dashboard via nice and
clean way into our app
this way we get a portal that thanks to
a unified ux and style it's very
difficult for the customers to notice
where your power bi dashboard ends and
the our shiny application begins
of course to be able to embed a power bi
dashboard you'll need a few things
first of all of course the power bi
desktop software because with this
software you'll be creating your battery
at desktop power bi dashboards
you'll also definitely need the power bi
service because after all that is where
your reports will be published too
with the power bi service you could
technically embed your power bi
dashboards already using iframes however
if you want to embed it using the power
bi API you'll also need power bi
dedicated capacity which can you can
either get via power bi premium or power
bi embedded
keep in mind however that this option
will be a bit more pricey but I hope to
convince you in the next slide why this
extra cost actually might be worth it
so the easiest solution is using iframes
to embed your power bi dashboard however
this comes with some very big
disadvantages
first you'll have to authenticate again
in each iframe which means that the
customer will have to log in for each
dashboard that it wants to see
and there are also no interactions
possible between your power bi dashboard
and your our shiny app
these disadvantages are negated by using
API embedding
because uh thanks to the power bi API
you can integrate an automatic into
authentication and with the API you can
also catch all the interactions which
means that you can actually have your
our shiny app communicate with your
power bi dashboard
this way you can create bookmarks apply
and delete filters and and many many
many more options
but how does one embedded power bi
dashboard into another shiny app you may
ask well fortunately for us Microsoft
offers a lot of examples on how to embed
a power bi dashboard using the API
unfortunately however
um there is no clear example of how to
do it using a r shiny
lucky for us and probably unlucky for
others there's JavaScript to the rescue
via the power bi JavaScript library you
can actually embed a power bi dashboard
using JavaScript
this means that your our shiny app and
the JavaScript files will have to
communicate with each other
on the our shiny website there's already
a very nice overview of how to set up
the interactions between your R and your
JavaScript
a brief overview so send custom meshes
can be used in your our application to
trigger JavaScript functions or
JavaScript code
these triggers can be read and caught
using the add custom message Handler in
your JavaScript files
and to send input back from your
JavaScript to your shiny application the
shiny dots on input change button can be
used
a quick example of how we use these
functions in our app
so when a user navigates in your our
shiny app to a page where there should
be a power bi dashboard we will call the
send custom message function which we'll
call the embed API function in your
JavaScript files with this custom
message will also send some parameters
for our report
next in the power bi
embeds.js Javascript file the add custom
message Handler will catch this column
mat API and using some magic JavaScript
code we can actually and using the
library we can embed the power bi
dashboards at a specific container in
our shiny app
when it's done rendering we will let our
app know that the report has been
rendered by using the set input value
and our our shiny app can continue with
its next step or steps in the in the
process
to realize the authentication and the
more complex interactions some more
complex embedding steps are needed
we won't go into too much detail in this
talk but I can share with you already
the tip of the embedding iceberg
for authentication we use the Azure alt
package this together with the HTTR
package for retrieving the embed token
made it possible to integrate the
authentication within our shiny app so
no more to different authentications
necessary
the power B API the power bi API was
then used to create bookmarks to apply
and delete filters and so on and so on
I want to conclude with a brief overview
of how to embed a power bi dashboard
into a shiny app for everyone just
tuning in this is probably one of the
most important slides of our talk
so we start by getting an access token
via Azure with this access token we can
get the embed URL from the power bi API
and with this URL together with
JavaScript we can render our power bi
reports in a container in our app
keep in mind however that you will need
power bi embedded capacity for this to
work
now for the closing thoughts of the
stock I want to give the spotlight back
to my colleague Thomas
so what lessons have we learned today
align your power bi style and your
layout within your Chinese app if you
can see where the shiny ends and your
power Beacon your power bi begins you
are doing it right
uh be mindful and aware of some Cloud
costs and add login where you can uh
shiny can lock power bi actions as well
so at the start of the presentation I
mentioned this those were the check
marks but we did we cover them all uh we
covered some debunking choices we have
seen some examples of a shining
production
um yeah you can find our code samples
via the link on the slide where you can
find step-by-step documents created with
a coacto and but we did we didn't cover
a reference to a famous man in a bow tie
so without further Ado That's all folks
thank you
all right thank you everybody
um any questions from the audience
if not I will read off of slido
all right for Thomas and yoran uh why
did you decide to integrate bi for the
portal into shiny instead of the other
way around at my Org the audience for bi
is bigger than our exclamation point
um so we think that with using our shiny
you have a lot more options than just
staying in power bi
um which is why we chose to actually do
it this way it's also a very interesting
uh concept to embed a power bi dashboard
in a shiny up and shiny offers way more
options and customizability than than
power bi you're not stuck in the in the
logic of power bi you have more freedom
which is also what the customer wanted
so we chose for a for this way of
working
okay we have time for
more so um how did you ensure both PBI
and shiny uh use the same data
um that's a very interesting question
which
um I don't have the answer to right now
um but yeah definitely come come look at
us at our booth and we can discuss this
in finer detail
any questions from the audience I've got
one more on slido
all right
um do you know if other bi tools like
Tableau have API driven authentication
like power bi does
absolutely
do you know if other bi tools like
Tableau have API driven authentication
like Tower bi does
so we believe that the same setup could
actually also be achieved with the with
wwrs also an API for embedding however
we chose for power bi in this case
because our customer was already heavily
relying on the Microsoft stack which
made it an obvious choice to choose
power bi um to embed but it is also
possible with the wapi
[Music]